hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to house i'm gonna try
to make this
the finale i think well there's two more
these weren't endings though some of
these weren't that easy are all these
clues
they're starting to blur together i'm
thinking that there's two more
endings and it's got something to do
with this clock i'm not sure what though
there's nothing else in the basement
that i need
the neighbor is unhelpful there's got to
be something
you no go that's not gonna work is it
uh no go oh god it's gonna go
you no go you're gonna go
oh you're still going aren't you all
right well whatever
sister oh oh oh oh oh oh the
the slingshot right what do you think of
this what do you think of this
i feel so alone no what do you think of
the slingshot goddammit i didn't get her
before she got in bed
oh god perhaps there are worse things
than death in this house will you hold
me sure
um maybe there's something that happens
like when she goes to bed
oh hi
okay oh miss you dolly don't ever leave
me again okay fine well that didn't do
anything
oh god damn it wow all right fine
uh fine fine fine fine maybe i gotta do
something to the doll
maybe the doll's like the source of her
depression and she can
only be free from whence the doll is
dead maybe that might be a thing this
the doll has been kind of talking to me
what if i kill the doll but save all of
my family
is that a thing what if i kill my sister
when she's holding the doll it's the
only way to break the curse for good
we all know this to be true okay here
you go
thanks for bringing her i miss you dolly
don't ever leave me again
okay i won't or the doll won't i guess
but that didn't do anything tv
no hey buddy how are you doing
welcome to the party pal you're gone
oh where are you going where are you
going
where are you going hello hi what are
you doing
the carpet with the spot on the floor
[Music]
daddy's home
what what happened your sister's song
fills the house the dark burns away as
the sound echoes throughout
deep shadows retreat from your father's
eyes the curse lifts
at but at what cost but at what cost
what at what cost i don't know mom's
dead i guess wait
wait so this whole time i thought i was
done with the sister but there was one
more step the whole time and it was just
giving her the doll
well that wasn't readily apparent fine
hi it's the doll
hi so you're still at it huh didn't you
hear what i
said just give up won't you this is your
reality now
there's no way out stop trying just
accept your faith won't you
stop resisting destiny i won't tell you
again it never ends
it never ends well i got another ending
i don't really get that one
but i got it so that's good there's got
to be a way
to beat the house in general right let
me check the journal
the song i can i remember when father
would hum that song to us before bed
it always put us at ease it just hurts
my ears now well that's not very nice
i mean i know your sister isn't very
good at playing the whatever the
instrument that was
ooh see okay that
that looks interesting there's got to be
something into that maybe i got to shoot
it
right well into bed what if i sprint no
it's i was like i was what if i spray
water on it it'll short-circuit it
i'm pretty sure it's not a electric but
damn okay shoot damn it
damn it oh
[Music]
oh
hi hello melody always hated that axe i
miss her so
much but that's his gun isn't it
you can see me yeah i sure can i knew i
never should have come to this house
yeah you're right it's more use to you
now to take care of it
i don't think your father likes me very
much yeah it smells terrible in here
yeah sure it is
feels like time has stopped completely
what day is it i don't know
melody hates bullying we used to bond
over that i'm gonna crush your skull bam
um okay oh oh
[Music]
slingshot nah
ah come on oh got you oh got ya
oh that's normal nope nope
do i drop a bowling ball on you oh no
you know no
i'm just gonna try to figure out i'm
just gonna explore there's no way that
i'm gonna figure out what i need to do
oh hey bud how you doing pal good to see
you bud
okay hey you're
[Music]
you
a thingy's gonna get me
you're gonna make a finger pop out of
the ground and squeeze my brain
okay but hey we're on to something
so we just got to get to this other
world place
and then we just are good to go right
doesn't matter who we kill i don't think
we need any good ending we just need to
get the action we need to chop it right
does it matter if i have the snail
i don't think it does does it
pabio tabby i can't stop seeing it yeah
yeah oh wait no you still haven't gotten
over this
oh come on yeah okay you're not gonna
let me do it anyway are you so all i
need is the axe but i have a funny
feeling i'm also gonna need the gun
kind of a big deal let's go chop
ourselves a
clock
whack no whack
right
okay so there were the
oh yeah you ah
well that means that's pretty easy my
running ain't too good
okay yeah what do i do straight down oh
that doesn't sound good
okay you what do i do about you what do
i do oh
ah what do i do okay ah
okay um you're just dancing there aren't
you
oh you're cute okay is it a bowling ball
thing
eat that bowling ball eat it eat
it eat it eat that bowling ball
didn't eat it didn't eat it it didn't
eat it at all okay what are you doing
what are you doing which way you're
going
oh oh my god oh what am i doing
oh my god
[Music]
all right so that's not the way to do it
so if it's not the bowling ball then
what is it
that's nothing oh the the bear trap of
course he'll swallow it and
clamp down in his throat or something
like that hey snaily you uh
you better now you okay you're doing all
right
okay i'm gonna pick you up hey it
doesn't let me okay so that's good
because i do like the ability to run is
very nice
uh do i have everything i need did i get
both bullets i did
right okay i'm good bam okay
easy and then i shoot these for some
reason bam
bam okay got those oh
okay so now oh my god okay so you
you you you you oh my god where is it oh
take some of that
oh god it didn't take that it didn't
take that why didn't you take that
oh okay okay okay
okay interesting very interesting oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god okay
what if i oh what if i oh
okay oh god oh hey
ha okay hey okay
cool all right let's go to the kitchen
instead of that
no there's nothing in the kitchen okay
so what do i gotta do in here just stay
mobile away from the
freaking trap oh my god
you shuck what do i do i'm gonna chop
that girl
goddamn
oh i should have shot it why didn't i
shoot it am i dumb
am i dumb am i honestly dumb i might
actually be dumb
don't answer that question so this time
i'm not gonna be
dumb about it i'm actually gonna be
smart
about can you please oh my god okay
there you go and drop nice
nice okay and this time i'm just gonna
straight up
shoot you staying mobile saying mobile
no
oh no maybe i chop it
how what is that about
[Music]
you wanna ask me why that's fair that
you're able to come through the walls
and uh get me
that's a little weird oh maybe there i
use the bear trap
you son of a you think you can
just run
me down you cannot
you cannot okay and then drop all right
perfect
okay and then axe i'm guessing
there's no harm in laying that down yeah
okay so if i stay
let me try it's it's i got to be up and
down right
oh oh oh that's oh there's more than one
why are you so quick
that's not fair what the hell is that
about
the hell is that about the hell okay
so what i gotta do is i gotta be in up
and down and then go out the door
first the bear trap's a bunk so it's
that's not what it
is that's not what it is at all so i'm
just gonna go up and down
oh my god really there we go and then go
out the door
oh there we go no go up and down
oh up and downy why'd i go righty tighty
oh so it's axe and then it's uppy downy
that's the thing i can get one kill
in first oh oh yeah okay got it
then go out in oh god you
son of a oh two
[Music]
how many are there i guess a whole
hand's worth
there's more than one there's apparently
more than one
okay there's another one okay let's go
again
okay got him oh one more if it's five
that would make sense
oh my god it's not making sense
[Music]
oh
is it 10 i bet it's 10 10 fingers would
make sense
i hate that it takes so long
to get back to that's what i really
don't like is like if there's something
that requires like some
skill like i'm fine with that but when
it takes
so long just to try again
ah it just it's irksome it's irksome you
know it's
just irksome it's just
irksome it irks me you know i get irked
i'm irked right now i'm rather
irked you know i'm just a little irked
but it's fine
i know there's two of you no there's not
two of you what the hell is happening
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
am i stupid am i stupid hang on let me
look something up here because
because the question will be answered on
the next episode of distractible that
you can hear
on your favorite podcasting forum
let's see and hit him with a detectable
promo
make it wig make it bombastic
make it blasphemous uh maybe not
blasphemous yeah definitely make it
blasphemous
no messing around this time maybe
there's a way that i could get
because i know that maybe i could just
get not to trigger
the other dude okay i think i got that
okay damn it
got it
[Music]
huh i did
i did oh my god what is that oh it's a
heart okay
um okay oh oh my god oh my god no no no
no no oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
what do i do oh my god what do i do huh
what do i do they're so close now um
okay if i can get across the hall okay
if i can get across
here there's a pocket down here yeah
what do we do shoot it or shoot them
what do i do
who do i shoot oh lay down uh lay down
this
and run him over it yes okay and then
oh
god that took forever snail
hello
snail buddy how
oh it's like the ending earthbound on a
gygax go on without me tabby i need to
catch my breath
okay fair enough i guess but where
though
um hello
okay so that's edge of map there okay oh
mom mama
okay stippy stumpy stumpy on you
mom
i can't run oh hey rat
hi uh okay
top of map all right
oh what the hell what the hell is that
the hell is that oh oh
hi oh
i don't wanna i don't think i should
oh okay you mustn't leave
um we've been having so much fun
you need me i don't think i do old man
ow what the oh
holy
yeah fair play um cool
oh
you're a fool a fool a dumb
insignificant
hey what are you doing wait stop there's
no hard feelings right
go ahead and leave i won't get in your
way okay okay i lied it it does end
please
what chunk indeed oh
oh ah
it feels like so long ago that house my
family
my arm it felt like a dream
like i wasn't in control but i'm free
i'm moving on my own now what a
beautiful day
you mean i really lost my arm after all
that and maybe my family too i guess now
that i think about it
well that's oh
uh
dream dream dream dream dream
dream journal journal oh
i knew it sometimes i find myself
dreaming about this place
i can feel it pulling me back like i
never even left
but i remind myself this time it's just
a dream an old memory
well apparently not okay i don't know
what those are about
i don't know what that's all about i
don't know what the old man is all about
i don't know what any of that is all
about but apparently there's two more
endings
interesting but what has changed has
anything changed
wha what are you a potted plant that i
could water
i'm not gonna do that now i don't have
time but anyway if there is more to this
that i need to know
let me know down in the comments below
um great game
really good stuff i suspect that that
might have been like an
ending and maybe there's like an
ultimate ultimate ending like that was a
true ending and then there's like a
secret true ending you know how they do
sometimes with these games
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out other games that i've played
that are like this i've probably linked
them down in the comments below or in
the description below
maybe in the suggested videos over there
and uh
yeah thanks again for watching and as
always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]